Desde hacía días se venía especulando
sobre una posible renuncia de la
ministra de la defensa alemana y fue
precisamente la ministra de la defensa
Cristina lambert la que confirmó este
lunes su dimisión en un comunicado muy
corto langred venía siendo criticada
Desde hacía varios meses por su Estilo
de comunicación pero también por varias
fallas que habían llevado a miembros de
la oposición pero también a políticos
cercanos al gobierno a cuestionar su
liderazgo y que también habían llevado
algunos de los socios internacionales de
Alemania poner en duda el compromiso
alemán en particular en lo que se
refiere a la ayuda militar destinada a
Ucrania y es que el Ministerio de
defensa es uno muy importante para
Alemania en la actualidad no solamente
porque tiene la labor de coordinar esas
ayudas a Ucrania en el plano
internacional sino también porque es el
encargado de liderar de llevar a cabo
una muy importante reforma militar en
Alemania de ahí que la renuncia del
hambre sea para sols para el canciller
también un momento muy difícil no
solamente porque los dos políticos serán
considerados muy cercanos sino también
porque soles ahora deberá demostrar
deberá tomar medidas para que el
Ministerio de defensa deje de ser uno de
los puntos más débiles de su gobierno